but what's interesting about it is the
president was urged on that call to
bring up the issue of corruption and
indeed in the readout of that call the
White House misleadingly said he did but
now that we've seen the record we see
that he didn't and notwithstanding
counsels claim in their trial brief that
the president raised the issue of
corruption in his phone call the July
25th call of course that word doesn't
appear in either conversation and why
because the only corruption he cared
about was the corruption that he could
help bring about now mr. Sibal Oney mr.
sip alone made the representation that
Republicans were not even allowed in the
depositions conducted in the house now
I'm not going to suggest to you that mr.
sip alone would deliberately make a
false statement I will leave it to mr.
sip alone to make those allegations
against others but I will tell you this
he's mistaken he's mistaken every
Republican on the three investigative
committees was allowed to participate in
the depositions and more than that they
got the same time we did you show me
another proceeding another presidential
impeachment or other that had that kind
of access for the opposite party
now there were depositions in the
Clinton impeachment there were
depositions in the Nixon impeachment so
what they would say is some secret
process well they were the same private
depositions in these other impeachments
as well finally a couple last points
they make the argument the president was
not allowed in the Judiciary Committee
chaired by my colleague chairman adler
to be present to present evidence to
will have his counsel present that is
also just plain wrong just plain wrong
not going to suggest you they're being
deliberately misleading here but it is
just plain wrong you've also heard my
friends at the other table make attacks
on me and chairman adler you'll hear
more of that i'm
not gonna do them the dignity of
responding to them but I will say this
they make a very important point
although it's not the point I think
they're trying to make when you hear
them attack the house managers what
you're really hearing is we don't want
to talk about the president's guilt we
don't want to talk about the McConnell
resolution and how patently unfair it is
we don't want to talk about how how the
pardon afresh the expression
ass-backwards it is to have a trial and
then ask for witnesses and so we'll
attack the house managers because maybe
we can distract you for a moment from
what's before you maybe if we attack the
house managers you'll be thinking about
them instead of thinking about the guilt
of the president so you'll hear more of
that and every time you do every time
you hear them attacking the house
managers I want you to ask yourselves
away from what issue are they trying to
distract me what was the issue that came
up just before this what are they trying
to deflect my attention from why don't
they have a better argument to make on
the merits finally mr. Sekulow asks why
are we here why are we here well I'll
tell you why we're here because the
president used the power of his office
to coerce an ally at war with an
adversary at war with Russia use the
power of his office to withhold hundreds
of millions of dollars of military aid
that you appropriated and we
appropriated to defend an ally and
defend ourselves because it's our
national security as well and why to
fight corruption that's nonsense and you
know it he would held that money and he
withheld even meeting with him in the
Oval Office the president of Ukraine
because he wanted to coerce Ukraine into
these sham investigations of his
opponent that he was terrified would
beat him in the next election that's
what this is about you want to say
that's okay their brief says that's okay
a president has a right to do it on
article two we heard the president he
can do whatever he wants you want to say
that's okay then you got to say that
every future president can come into
office and they
and do the same thing are we prepared to
say that well that's why we're here I
now yield to represent of Lofgren mr.
chief justice senators counsel for the
president the house managers strongly
support Senator Schumer's amendment
which would ensure a fair legitimate
trial based on a full evidentiary record
the Senate can remedy president Trump's
unprecedented cover-up by taking a
straightforward step it can ask for the
key evidence that the president has
improperly blocked Senator Schumer's
amendment does just that the amendment
authorizes a subpoena for White House
documents that are directly relevant to
this case these documents focus on the
president's scheme to strong-arm Ukraine
to announce an investigation into as a
political opponent to interfere with the
2020 election the documents will reveal
the extent of the White House's
coordination with the president's agents
such as ambassador Sandlin and Rudy
Giuliani
who pushed the president's so-called
drug deal on Ukrainian officials the
documents will also show us how key
players inside the White House such as
the president's acting chief of staff
Nick Mulvaney and his deputy Robert
Blair helped set up the deal by
executing the freeze on all military aid
and withholding a promised visit to the
White House the dockets include records
of the people who may have objected to
this scheming such as ambassador Bolton
this is an important impeachment case
against the president the most important
documents are going to be at the White
House the documents Senator Schumer's
amendment targets would provide more
clarity and context about president
Trump scheme the amendment prevents the
president from hiding evidence as he is
previously
tried to do now the house subpoenaed
these documents as part of the
impeachment inquiry but the president
completely rejected this and every
document subpoena from the house as
powerful as our evidence is and make no
mistake it overwhelmingly approves who's
his guilt we did not receive a single
document from the executive branch
agency including the White House itself
recent revelations from press reports
Freedom of Information Act requests and
additional witnesses such as Lev Parnas
underscore how relevant these documents
and therefore why the president has been
so desperate to hide them and his
misconduct from Congress and from the
American people a trial without all the
relevant evidence is not a fair trial it
would be wrong for you senators acting
as judges to be deprived of relevant
evidence of the president's offenses
when you are judging these most serious
charges it would also be unfair to the
American people who overwhelmingly
believe the president should produce all
relevant documents in evidence now
documentary evidence is used in all
trials for simple reason as the story
goes the documents don't lie documents
give objective real-time insight into
the events under investigation the need
for such evidence is especially
important in Senate impeachment trials
more than 200 years of Senate practice
make clear that documents are generally
the first order of business they
presented been presented to the Senate
before witnesses take the stand in great
volume to ensure the Senate has the
evidence it needs to evaluate the case
now documentary evidence and Senate
trials has never been limited to the
documents sent by the House the Senate
throughout its existence has exercised
its authority pursuant to its clear
rules of procedure to subpoena documents
at the outset of a trial
we don't know with certainty what the
documents will say we simply want the
truth what whatever that truth may be so
so do the American people they want to
know the truth and so should everybody
in this chamber regardless of our party
affiliation there are key reasons why
this amendment is necessary we'll begin
by walking through the history and
precedent of Senate impeachment trials
I'll let you know about the houses
efforts to get the documents which were
met by the president and his
administration's categorical commitment
to hide all the evidence at all costs
and will address the specific need for
these subpoenaed White House documents
I'll tell you why these documents are
needed now not at the end of the trial
in order to ensure a full fair trial
based on a complete evidentiary record
now some have suggested incorrectly that
the Senate is limited only to evidence
gathered before the House approved its
articles of impeachment others have
suggested ink also incorrectly that it
would somehow be strange for the Senate
to issue subpoenas these claims are
without any historical presidential or
legal support over the past two
centuries the Senate has always
understood that its sole power under the
Constitution to try all impeachments
requires the Senate to sit as a court of
impeachment and hold a trial in fact the
founders assign sole authority only
twice in the Constitution first giving
the house sole authority to impeach and
second giving the Senate sole authority
to try that at each one if the founders
had intended for the Senate to serve as
some kind of appellate body you know
they would have said that but no instead
they wrote this article 1 section 3 the
Senate shall have the sole power to try
all impeachments
the Senate has always received the
relevant documents in impeachment trials
and indeed the Senate
rules of procedure and practice make
clear that new evidence will be
considered precedent shows this all 15
full centered impeachment trials
considered new evidence let's look at a
few examples that show the Senate takes
new evidence in impeachment trials the
first ever presidential impeachment
trial in 1868 against President Andrew
Johnson allowed the house management
managers to spend the first two days of
the trial introducing new documentary
evidence it was the same in Judge John
Pickering's trial in 1804 new documents
were presented to the Senate nearly a
week before house managers made their
opening statement and later throughout
the trial and has been mentioned earlier
by mr. Schiff in modern times in 2010
George Porteous impeachment trial
included seven months of pretrial
discovery and six thousand pages of
documentary evidence admitted at trial
after that evidence was admitted the
Senate held its trial President
Clinton's case did not involve subpoenas
for documents now why was that because
President Clinton had already produced a
huge trove of documents the Independent
Counsel turned over to Congress some
90,000 pages of relevant documents
gathered during the course of his years
long investigation and I remember as a
member of the Judiciary Committee going
over to the Ford building looking at the
boxes of the document but even with all
those documents the Clinton trial
included the opportunity to present new
evidence and the admission of additional
documents and three witnesses the
Clinton impeachment president also shows
how president from profuse aloose any
relevant documents and response to
congressional subpoenas is different
than past presidents different from
President Clinton different from
President Johnson unless even the
President Nixon in short not a single
president has categorically refused to
cooperate with an impeachment
investigation
not a single president has issued a
blanket direction to his administration
to produce no documents and no witnesses
these are the precedents the Senate must
rely on the Senate should issue a
subpoena for documents at the very
outset of the proceedings so that this
body the house managers the president
can all account for those documents in
their presentations and deliberations it
doesn't make sense to request and
receive documents after the parties
present their cases the time is now to
do that so why is the amendment needed
to prevent President Trump from
continuing his categorical commitment to
hide the evidence in this case the house
sought White House documents why don't
we have them it's not because we didn't
try it's because the White House refused
to give them to us
the president's defense team seems to
believe that the White House is
permitted to completely refused to
provide any documents without regard to
whether or not it is privileged they
apparently believe that Congress's
Authority is subject to the approval of
the President
but that's not what the Constitution
says our Constitution sets forth a
democracy with a system of checks and
balances to ensure that no one and
certainly not the president is above the
law now even President Nixon produced
more than 30 transcripts of White House
recordings and notes from meetings with
the president here even before the house
launched the investigation that led to
this trial President Trump
rejected Congress's constitutional
responsibility to use its lawful
authority to investigate his actions he
asserted that his administration was
fighting all the subpoenas proclaiming I
have an article to or I have the right
to do whatever I want as president here
is what he said then I have an article
to where I have the right to do whatever
I want as present
even after the house formally announced
its investigation of the president's
conduct in Ukraine the president still
continued his obstruction beginning on
September 9th 2019 the house
investigative committees made two
attempts to voluntarily obtain documents
from the White House the White House
refused to engage with frankly or even
respond to the house committee's on
October 4th the House Committee on
Oversight and Reform said a subpoena to
White House acting chief of staff Mick
Mulvaney this time compelling the
production of documents from the White
House by October 18th on October 8th
before the White House documents were
due the White House Counsel sent a
letter to Speaker Pelosi stating the
president's position that the present
Trump and his administration cannot
participate in this partisan inquiry
under these circumstances the president
simply declared that he will not
participate in an investigation he
didn't like ten days later on October
18th the White House Counsel sent a
letter to the house confirming that it
would continue to stonewall the White
House Counsel again stated the president
refused to participate well the
Constitution article 1 section 2 since
the house shall have the sole power of
impeachment just as in article 1 section
3 the Senate has a sole power to try
participation in a duly authorized
congressional investigation isn't
optional it's not up to the President to
decide whether to participate or not the
Constitution gives the house the sole
power of impeachment it gives the Senate
the sole power to try all impeachments
the president may not like being
impeached but if the it's the president
not the if the president not the
Congress decides when impeachment
proceedings are appropriate then the
impeachment power is no power at all and
if you let him block
from Congress and from the American
people the evidence to cover up his
offenses than the impeachment power
truly will be meaningless with all the
back-and-forth about these documents
we've heard the phrase executive
privilege
the president has lawyers keep saying
and they talk about vast legal rights to
justify hiding the truth withholding
information but that's a distraction
that's not what the Constitution
provides and the truth is as it's been
mentioned by mr. Schiff in the course of
the entire impeachment inquiry President
Trump has not once asserted executive
privilege not a single time it was not
the reason provided by mr. Cipollini for
refusing to comply with the house's
subpoena indeed President Trump didn't
offer legal justification for
withholding the evidence here's the
truth
presidents members of Congress judges
and the Supreme Court have recognized
throughout our nation's history that
Congress's investigative power are at
their absolute peak during impeachment
proceedings your powers executive
privilege cannot be a barrier to give
absolute secrecy to cover up wrongdoing
if it did the House and the Senate would
see their power disappear when President
Nixon tried that argument by refusing to
produce tape recordings to prosecutors
and to Congress he was soundly rebuked
by the other two branches of government
the Supreme Court unanimously ruled
against him the House Judiciary
Committee voted that he be impeached for
obstruction of Congress it would be
remarkable for the United States Senate
to declare for the first time in our
nation's history that the president has
an absolute right to decide whether his
own impeachment trial is legitimate and
it would be extraordinary for the Senate
to refuse to seek important documentary
evidence especially when the president
has yet to assert any privilege to
justify
withholding documents now there's
another reason this amendment is
important the documents sought are
directly relevant to the president's
misconduct the White House is concealing
documents involving officials who have
direct knowledge of key events at the
heart of this trial this isn't just a
guess we know these documents exist from
the witnesses who testified in the house
and from other public release of
documents and let's walk through those
specific documents that the White House
should send to the Senate
they include among other documents
relating to president Trump's direct
communications with President Solinsky
president Trump's request for political
investigations including communications
with Rudy Giuliani ambassador Soglin and
others president from unlawful whole of
the 391 million dollars of military aid
concerns that White House officials
reported to NSC legal counsel in
real-time the president's decision to
recall ambassador Murray Jovanovic from
Ukraine the first set of documents the
Senate should get about president
Trump's communication with the president
of Ukraine would include the phone calls
on April 21st and July 25th as well as
the September 25th 2019 meeting with
President Solinsky in New York we know
for example that NSC officials prepared
talking points for the president in
preparation for both calls with the
Ukrainian president the talking points
were about American policy as reflected
by the votes of Congress as well as the
Trump administration itself they didn't
include any mention of the Biden's
or the 2016 election interference or
investigations that President Trump
requested on the July 25th call here's a
clip of Lieutenant Colonel VIN Minh
explaining how the president ignored the
points about
American policy reflecting the views of
both the Congress in the Trump
administration Colonel Whitman if I
could turn your attention to the April
21st call that is the first call between
President Trump and president stilinski
did you prepare a talking points for the
president to use during that call yes I
did and did those talking points include
rooting out corruption in Ukraine yes
that was something the president was
supposed to raised in the conversation
with President Solinsky those were the
recommended talking points that were
cleared through the NSC staff for the
president yes the materials provided for
the July 25th call that Lieutenant
Colonel ven Minh mentioned are highly
relevant they could help confirm that
the president's actual statements to
President Zelaya Zielinski were
unrelated to the foreign policy
objectives of his own administration and
show that they served his own personal
interests at the expense of America's
national security interests these
documents also include handwritten notes
and other documents that White House
officials generated during the calls and
meetings we know for example that
lieutenant-colonel vin Minh Mr Morrison
Jennifer Williams all testified to
taking contemporaneous handwritten notes
during the July 25th call Ms Williams
and Lieutenant Colonel VIN Minh both
testified that President Solinsky made
an explicit reference to BIR yzma that
was not included in the memorandum that
the White House released to the public
here's a clip of their testimony both of
you recall President Solinsky in that
conversation raising the issue or
mentioning burr yzma do you not that's
correct
correct and yet the word burr yzma
appears nowhere in the call record
that's been released to the public is
that right
that's right correct why you need
documents generated after the calls and
meetings they would shed light on how
these events were perceived in the White
House and what actions were taken moving
forward
for example National Security Advisor
John Bolton wasn't on the 25th call but
he was apparently informed about the
contents of the call afterward his
reaction once he was informed would be
helpful to understanding the extent to
which president Trump's action deviated
from American policy and American
security interests there's another set
of documents that the Senate should get
and they relate to the political
investigations that President Trump and
his agents repeatedly asked Ukrainian
officials to announce these documents
about efforts to pressure Ukraine to
announce investigations and the decision
to place a whole on military aid to
Ukraine they would be very important for
you to in valuate the president's
conduct for example ambassador Bolton is
a first-hand witness to president
Trump's abuse of power he reported
directly to the president he supervised
the entire staff of the National
Security Council public reports indicate
that John Bolton is a voracious
note-taker in every meeting from witness
testimony we know that ambassador Bolden
hosted the July 10th 2019 meeting where
ambassador Sandlin told Ukrainian
officials that the promised White House
meeting would be scheduled if they
announced the investigations we know
Bolton was briefed about this meeting
immediately following it when
ambassador's Sandlin said he had a deal
with Mick Mulvaney to schedule the
promised White House meeting if Ukraine
announced investigations into the
Biden's in the 2016 election we also
know ambassador Bolton was involved in
briefing the president on a presidential
decision memorandum in August reflecting
the consensus interagency opinion that
Ukrainian security assassins
was vital to America's national security
something that Congress had approved
appropriated something the president had
signed press reports indicate that he
too was involved in a late August oval
office meeting where he secretary Pompeo
and secretary Esper all tried to
convince the President to release the
aide now ambassador Bolton's has come
forward and publicly confirmed that he
was a witness to important events but
also that he has new evidence that no
one has seen yet if we know there is
evidence that's not yet come out all of
us should want to hear it we should want
to hear it now before ambassador bolton
testifies we should get documents and
records relating to his testimony
including his notes which would provide
contemporaneous evidence about what was
discussed in meetings related to Ukraine
to Ukraine which would help to evaluate
his testimony the evidence is not just
restricted to ambassador Bolton during
his public testimony ambassador Gordon
Sandlin stated I have not had access to
all my phone records he also said that
he and his lawyers had asked repeatedly
for these materials
he said the materials would help reflect
his memory we should look at those that
material ambassador's song also
testified that he exchanged a number of
emails with top officials like Mick
Mulvaney about his efforts to pressure
Ukraine to announce the investigations
president Trump demanded here's his
testimony third let me say precisely
because we did not think that we were
engaging in improper behavior we made
every effort to ensure that the relevant
decision-makers at the National Security
Council and the State Department knew
the important details of our efforts the
suggestion that we were engaged in some
irregular or rogue diplomacy is
absolutely false I have now identified
certain State Department emails and
messages that provide contemporaneous
support for my view these emails show
that the leadership of the State
Department the National Security Council
and the White House were all informed
about the Ukraine efforts from May 23rd
2019 until the security aid was released
on September 11th 2019 these emails
among others are in the possession of
hope precise these emails referenced in
this testimony are in the possession of
the White House the State Department and
even the Department of Energy
since officials from all three entities
communicated together you know during
his testimony ambassador sanli described
it this way everyone was in the loop it
was no secret these emails are therefore
important to understanding the full
scope of the scheme the request for
relevant evidence is not confined to
trump administration officials the
Senate should also get White House
records relating to the president's
private agents who acted on his behalf
in Ukraine including Rudy Giuliani
Victoria tensing and Jody due to Geneva
witness testimony and documents have
made clear that mr. Giuliani a frequent
visitor to the White House who also
received and made frequent calls to the
White House was acting on behalf of the
President to press Ukrainian officials
to announce investigations that would
personally and politically benefit the
president for example the May 10th 2019
letter from mr. Giuliani to
president-elect szalinski that's shown
on this slide states he was acting quote
as personal counsel to President Trump
with his knowledge and consent he
requested a meeting with the
president-elect and he and he to be
joined by MS tensing who is quote
we familiar with this matter the
evidence indicates he was collaborating
with Miss tensing and mr. Geneva in this
effort the Senate should get the White
House records of meetings of calls
involving mr. Giuliani is tensing or mr.
Duchin 'va these records are important
to help you understand the extent to
which the White House was involved in
mr. Giuliani's efforts to coerce Ukraine
to announce the investigations the
president wanted the records would also
show how the president's personal
political agenda became more important
than policies to help America's national
security interests the President's
Council may consistent with his prior
attempts to hide evidence assert that
attorney-client privilege would cover
these documents but the president's
personal attorney-client privilege
cannot shield evidence of misconduct in
office or that of his aides or his
lawyers participation in corrupt schemes
we aren't asking for documents
reflecting legitimate legal advice you
need documents about their actions to
pressure Ukraine to announce an
investigation into president Trump's
political opponent there's a set of
White House documents that relate
directly to press the president's
unlawful decision to withhold 391
million dollars appropriated bipartisan
to help Ukraine witnesses have testified
that President from directly ordered a
hold on the Security Assistance
despite the u Nana's opinion of his
agencies that the aid should be released
importantly according to the Government
Accountability Office his action
violated the law On January 16 2020 the
GAO an independent watchdog issued a
legal opinion finding that president
from violated the law when he held up
security assistance to Ukraine the GAO
said and I quote faithful execution of
the law
does not permit the president to
substitute his own policy priorities for
those that Congress enacted into law
OMB withheld funds for a policy reason
which is not permitted under the
impoundment Control Act the withholding
was not a programmatic delay therefore
we conclude that OMB violated the ica
the fact that the president's action to
freeze the aid which he used a pressure
Ukraine to announce the political
investigations he wanted was against not
only the official confence
consensus of his own administration but
also against the law and it was to help
himself that helps demonstrate these
actions were taken for president Trump's
personal and political benefit witness
testimony and public reporting make
clear the White House has a significant
body of documents that relate to these
key aspects of the president's scheme
some of these documents outlined the
planning of the president's freeze for
example the New York Times reported in
June that mr. Mulvaney emailed his
senior advisor mr. Blair did we ever
find out about the money for Ukraine and
whether we can hold it back
this shows that mr. Mulvaney was an
email contact with his aides about the
very issues under investigation as part
of this impeachment it tells us that the
White House is in possession of
communications that go to the heart of
the charges before you the Senate should
also get materials prepared for summary
notes from a late August meeting with
President Trump Secretary of Defense
mark Esper and Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo when they tried to convince the
president that freeing and this is a
quote freeing up the money for Ukraine
was the right thing to do according to
the New York Times ambassador Bolton
told the president this is in America's
interests the Senate should review that
highly relevant document which reflects
real-time assertions by
president Trump's own senior aides that
Ukrainian aid was in the national
security interest of the United States
and that there was no legitimate reason
to hold up the aid there are documents
that include after-the-fact
justifications to try and overcome legal
problems and the Ananas objections to
freezing assistance to Ukraine and we
know these documents exist for example
on January 3rd 2020 OMB stated in a
letter to The New York Times that had it
had discovered 20 responsive documents
consisting of 40 pages reflecting emails
between White House official Robert
Blair and OMB official Michael Duffy
that relate directly to the freezing of
the Ukraine security assistance but OMB
wouldn't release them in a Freedom of
Information lawsuit and they have
refused to produce these documents at
the direction of the president in
response to the houses lawful subpoena
now the Washington Post reported that a
confidential White House review of
President Trump's decision to hold up
hundreds of documents that reveal
extensive efforts to generate and after
the fact justification for the debate
over whether the delay was legal that's
known as a cover-up actually the White
House lawyers had apparently uncovered
quote early August email exchanges
between acting chief of staff Mick
Mulvaney and White House budget
officials seeking to provide some
explanation for withholding the funds
the president had already ordered on
hole the documents also reportedly
include communications between White
House officials and outside agencies not
only does Congress have a right to see
them the public does - under freedom of
information laws as a matter of
constitutional authority the Senate has
the greatest interest in and right to
compel those documents indeed as the
news article explains White House
lawyers are reportedly quote worried
about unflattering exchanges and facts
that could at a minimum embarrass the
president perhaps they should be worried
about that but the risk of embarrassment
cannot outweigh the constitutional
interests in this impeachment proceeding
any evidence of guilt including further
proof of the real reason the President
ordered that funds withheld or after the
fact attempts to paper over knowingly
unlawful conduct they must be provided
to ensure a full and fair trial no
privilege or national security rationale
can be used as a shield from disclosing
misconduct there are key White House
documents relating to multiple instances
when White House officials reported
their concerns to White House lawyers
about the president's scheme to press
Ukraine to do the president a domestic
political favor for example Lieutenant
Colonel VIN Minh and dr. Hill both
informed NSC lawyers about the July 10th
meeting in which ambassadors Soglin
revealed he had a deal with mr. Mulvaney
I'm going to go directly to the clip by
dr. hill because dr. hill pardon me at
Bolton's direction also reported that
meeting - doctor - John Eisenberg as she
explained in her testimony I had a
discussion with ambassador Bolton both
after the meeting in his office a very
brief one and then one immediately after
the subsequent meeting so the subsequent
meeting after both meetings when you
spoke to him and relayed to him what
ambassador Sandlin said what did
ambassador Bolton say to you well I just
want to highlight first of all that
ambassador Bolton wanted me to hold back
in the room immediately after the
meeting again I was sitting on the sofa
with a colleague just in that second
meeting what it is because he was making
a very strong point that he wanted to
know exactly what was being said and
when I came back and will
to him he had some very specific
instruction for me and I'm presuming
that that's specific instruction was
that I had to go to the lawyers to John
Eisenberg our senior counsel for the
National Security Council to basically
say you tell Eisenberg and busted a
Bolton told me that I am not part of
this whatever drug deal that Mulvaney
and sundaland are cooking up what did
you understand him to mean by the drug
deal that Mulvaney and Sandlin were
cooking up I took it to mean
investigations for a meeting did you go
speak to the lawyers I certainly did and
you relayed everything that you just
told us and precisely and then the more
the details of how the meeting had
unfolded as well which I gave a full
description of this in my October 14
deposition there was something wrong
going on here and White House officials
were told repeatedly go tell the lawyers
about it
dr. hill Lieutenant Colonel VIN Minh mr.
Morrison who reported to mr. Eisenberg
at least two conversations we need the
notes of those documents to find out
what was said and again attorney-client
privilege cannot shield information
about misconduct from the impeachment
trial of the President of the United
States now it's interesting this
amendment is supported by 200 years of
precedent it's needed to prevent the
president from continuing to hide the
evidence and that's why the specific
documents requested are so important for
this case it's faithful to the
Constitution's provision that the Senate
shall have the sole power to try all
impeachments
the final point I'll make today concerns
urgency the Senate should act on this
subpoena now at the outset of the trial
in 14 of the Senate's 15 full
impeachment trials threshold evidentiary
matters including the timing nature and
scope of witness testimony and the
gathering of all relevant documents were
dressed at the very outset
the trial there are practical
considerations as why the subpoenas need
to be issued now resolving whether a
subpoena should issue now would let us
immediately engage with the White House
to resolve asserted legitimate privilege
issues if any exist and ensure you get
the documents as soon as possible so
they can be presented to the Senators in
advance of witness testimony waiting to
resolve these threshold matters until
after the parties have presented their
case would undercut the process of a
genuine credible trial
thus common-sense tradition and fairness
all compel that the amendment should be
adopted and it should be adopted now
members of the Senate for all the
reasons I walk through today I urge you
to support the amendment to issue a
subpoena for white house documents
documents that are directly relevant to
evaluating the president's scheme the
house did its job in the face of the
presence obstruction and categorical
commitment to hide the evidence we still
gather direct evidence of his conduct
and determined that his conduct required
impeachment the president complains
about due process in the house
investigation but he was not only
permitted to participate he was actually
required to participate yet he refused
to do so he refused to provide witnesses
and documents that would tell his side
of the story
so now it's up to you with the backing
of a subpoena authorized by the Chief
Justice of the United States you can end
president Trump's obstruction if the
Senate fails to take this step if it
won't even ask for this evidence this
trial and your verdict will be
questioned Congress and the American
people deserve the full truth there is
no plausible reason why anyone wouldn't
want to hear all of the available
evidence about the president's conduct
it's up to this body to make sure that
happened
it's up to you to decide whether the
Senate will affirm its sole power and
constitutional duty to try impeachments
whether and when it will get the
evidence that it needs to render a fair
verdict don't surrender to the present
stonewalling it will allow the president
to be above the law and deprive the
American people of truth in the process
a fair trial is essential in every way
important for the president who hopes to
be exonerated not merely acquitted by a
trial seen as unfair important for the
Senate whose vital role is to continue
to protect and defend the Constitution
of the United States which has preserved
our American Liberty for centuries and
finally important for the American
people who expect a quest for truth
fairness and justice history is watching
and the house managers urge that you
support the amendment and I reserve the
balance of my time Thank You counsel mr.
Sibal onie well mr. Philbin
[Music]
Thank You mr. chief justice
Majority Leader McConnell Democratic
leader Schumer senators it's remarkable
that after taking the action of the
breathtaking gravity of voting to
impeach the duly elected president of
the United States and after saying for
weeks that they had overwhelming
evidence to support their case the first
thing that the house managers have done
upon arriving finally in this chamber
after waiting for 33 days is to say well
actually we need more evidence we're not
ready to present our case we need to
have subpoenas and we need to do more
discovery because we don't have the
evidence we need to support our case
this is stunning it's a stunning
admission of the inadequate and broken
process that the House Democrats ran in
this impeachment inquiry that failed to
compile a record to support their
charges it's stunning that they don't
have the evidence they need to present
their case and that they don't really
have a case if a litigant showed up in
any court in this country on the day of
trial and said to the judge actually
your honor we're not ready to go we need
more discovery we need to do some more
subpoenas we need to do some more work
they'd be thrown out of court and the
lawyers would probably be sanctioned
this is not the sort of proceeding that
this body should condone now we've just
heard that this is so important let's
consider what's really at issue in the
resolution here and the amendment it's a
matter of timing it's a matter of when
this body will consider whether there
should be witnesses or subpoenas for
documents why is it that the managers
the house managers are so afraid to have
to present their case present remember
they've had weeks of a process that they
entirely controlled they had 17
witnesses who testified first in secret
and then in public they've compiled a
record with thousands of pages of
reports and they're apparently afraid to
just make a presentation based on the
record
that they compiled and then have you
decide whether there's any there there
whether there's anything worth trying to
talk to more witnesses about why is it
that they can't wait a few days to make
their presentation on everything they've
been preparing for weeks and then have
that issue considered because they don't
think that there is any they're there
and they want to ram this through now
and they want to ran this through now
when it's something that they themselves
fail to do so I want to unpack a couple
of the aspects of what they're asking
this body to do part of it relates to
the broken process in the house and how
that process was inadequate and invalid
and compiled an inadequate record a part
of it has to do with what accepting
their request to have this body do their
job for them would do to this
institution going forward and how it
would alter forever the relationship
between the House and the Senate and
impeachment proceedings so first as to
the process in the house what they're
asking the house manager asking this
body to do now is really to do their job
for them because they didn't take the
measures to pursue these documents in
the house proceedings and there been a
number of statements made about they
they tried to get the documents and no
executive privilege was asserted and
things like that let's look at what
actually happened they issued a subpoena
to the White House and the White House
explained and we were told a few minutes
ago that the White House provided no
response it provided no rationale that's
not true in a letter of October 18th
White House Counsel pet-sit bologna
explained in three pages of legal
argument why that subpoena was invalid
and that subpoena was invalid because it
was issued without authorization
we've heard a lot today about how the
Constitution assigns the sole power of
impeachment to the house that's right
that's what article 1 section 2 says
it assigns the sole power of impeachment
to the house not to any member of the
House and no Committee of the house can
exercise that authority to issue
subpoenas until it's been delegated that
authority by a vote of the house there
was no vote from the house instead
Speaker Pelosi held a press conference
and she purported by holding a press
conference on September 24th to delegate
the authority of the house to manager
Schiff and several other committees and
have them issue subpoenas all of those
subpoenas were invalid and that was
explained to the the house to manager
Schiff and the other chairmen of those
committees at the time in that October
18th letter did the house take any steps
to remedy that did they try to dispute
that did they go to court did they do
anything to resolve that problem no
because as we know all that they wanted
to do was issue subpoena and move on
they just wanted to get through the
impeachment process as quick as possible
and get it done before Christmas that
was their goal so those subpoenas were
unauthorized now what about some of the
other things that they brought up the
witnesses witnesses who were directed
not to testify and and part on this
we've heard managership say several
times that the White has never asserted
executive privilege well let me be clear
on it that's a lawyer's trick because it
is technically true that the White House
didn't assert executive privilege
because there's a particular situation
in which you do that in a particular way
that you do that but there's another
doctrine of immunity of senior advisors
to the president that is based on the
same principles as executive privilege
and that has been asserted by presidents
of both political parties since the
1970s at least so that's and this is
what one attorney-general explained
about that
quote the immunity such advisors enjoy
from testimonial compulsion by a
congressional committee is absolute and
may not be over borne by competing
congressional interests and quote that
was Attorney General Janet Reno in the
Clinton administration explaining that
senior advisors to the president are
immune from congressional compulsion and
that doctrine that immunity is rooted in
the same principles of executive
privilege it's been asserted by all
presidents since the 1970s and that was
the basis on which a number of the
advisers whose pictures they put up were
directed not to testify did they try to
challenge that in court did they go to
court on that one did they try to go
through the constitutionally mandated
accommodations process to see if there
was a way to come up with some aspect of
testimony could be provided no none of
that they just wanted to forge ahead
rush through the process not have the
evidence and then use that as another
charge in their charging sheet for the
impeachment calling it obstruction of
Congress and what that is is Professor
Turley explained this idea that when
there's a conflict between the executive
branch and the house and seeking
information and the president is
asserting constitutionally based
privileges that's part of the operation
of separation of powers that is the
president's constitutional duty to
defend the prerogatives of the office
for the future occupants of that office
and it is not something that can be
charged as an impeachable offense as the
House Democrats have tried to say here
to do that is an abuse of power that's
what Professor Turley explained it's
Congress's it's this House Democrats of
use of power
we just heard manager Lofgren refer to
executive privilege as a distraction
she was asserting that these issues of
executive privilege are just a
distraction that shouldn't hold things
up but this is what the Supreme Court
has said
about executive privilege and Nixon
versus United States that the
protections for confidentiality
executive privilege are quote
fundamental to the operations of
government and inextricably rooted in
the separation of powers under the
Constitution and quote inextricably
rooted in the separation of powers
that's why it's the president's duty to
defend executive branch confidentiality
interests and that is what the president
was doing here
now the process that they pursued in the
house abandoned any effort beyond
issuing the first subpoena that was
invalid to work out an accommodation
with the White House and instead just
tried to rush ahead to have the
impeachment done by Christmas what does
that lead to now they're coming to this
body after a process that was half-baked
that didn't compiled a record sufficient
to support their charges and asking this
body to do their job for them now as
leader McConnell pointed out and some
comments earlier today to allow that to
accept the idea that the house can bring
an impeachment here that is not
adequately supported that has not been
investigated that has not got a record
to support it and to turn this body into
the investigatory body would permanently
alter the relationship between the house
and the Senate and impeachment
proceedings it's not the role of the
Senate to have to do the houses job for
them it's not the role of the Senate to
be doing an investigation and to be
doing discovery in a matter like the
impeachment of a president of United
States if the house has not done the
investigation and cannot support its
case it's not the time once it arrives
here to start doing all that work that's
something that's the houses role so
this is something that is important for
this institution I believe not to allow
the house to turn it into a situation
where this body would have to be doing
the house's work for it if there is not
evidence to support the case if they
haven't done their investigation then
they're not going to be able to support
their case again what's at issue here
and I think it's important to recall on
the issue of this amendment it's not
whether the Senate whether this body
will be considering whether there should
be witnesses or not but but when that
should be considered and there is no
reason not to take the approach that was
done in the Clinton impeachment a
hundred senators agreed then that it
made sense to hear from both sides
before making determination on that to
hear from both sides to see what sort of
case the house could present and the
president's defense and that makes sense
in every trial system there is a
mechanism for determining whether the
parties have actually presented a
triable issue whether there is really
some there there that requires the
further proceedings and this body should
take that common-sense approach and hear
what it is that the house managers have
to say why are they afraid to present
their case they had weeks in a process
that they controlled to compile their
record and they should be able to make
that presentation now and the one point
that I will close on we've heard
managers shift say several times that it
did we have to have a fair process here
and I was struck by it that at one point
he said if you allow only one side to
present evidence the outcome will be
predetermined the outcome will be
predetermined that's exactly what
happened in the house let's recall that
the process they had in the house was
one-sided they locked the president and
his lawyers out there was no due process
the president they started with secret
hearings in the basement the president
couldn't be present work by looked by
his council he couldn't present evidence
he couldn't cross-examine witnesses and
then there was a second round in public
where again they locked the president
out and we've heard they just said that
the president had an opportunity to
participate in the third round of
hearings that they held before the
Judiciary Committee after one hearing on
December fourth speaker Pelosi on the
morning of December 5th went out and
announced the conclusion of the
judiciary committee proceedings she
announced that she was directing
chairman Nadler to draft articles of
impeachment that was before the day that
they had set for the president even to
tell them what rights he wanted to have
and to exercise in their proceedings it
was all already predetermined the
outcome had been predetermined the
Judiciary Committee had already decided
it was not going to have any fact
hearings there was no process for the
president he was never allowed to
participate so when chairmanship says
here that if you only allow one side to
present evidence that predetermines the
outcomes that's what they did in the
house because they had a predetermined
outcome there because it was all
one-sided and for him to lecture this
body now on what a fair process would be
take some gall a fair process would be
when you come to the day of trial be
ready to start the trial present your
case not ask for more discovery the
president is ready to proceed and the
house manager should be ready to proceed
and this amendment should be rejected
thank you the house managers have eight
minutes remaining
the house is certainly not asking the
Senate to do the houses job we're asking
the Senate to do its job to hold a trial
have you ever heard of a trial that
doesn't have evidence that doesn't have
witnesses that's what this amendment is
all about just a moment about the
subpoenas the president president Trump
refused to provide any information to
the House ordered all of his people to
stone Wallace now it's been suggested
that we should spend two or three years
litigating that question I was a young
law student actually working on the
Nixon impeachment many years ago and I
remember the day that the Supreme Court
issued its unanimous decision that the
President had to release the tapes I
think US v Nixon still governs the
president the house and the Senate
should not be required to litigate US v
Nixon back to the Supreme Court and down
again for it to be good law it is good
law the president has not complied with
those requirements to the detriment of
the truth this isn't about helping the
house this isn't about helping the
Senate this is about getting to the
truth and making sure that impartial
justice is done and that the American
people are satisfied that a fair trial
has been held I would yield now to my
colleague mr. Schiff
mr. Philbin says that the house has not
ready presents its case of course that's
not something you heard from any of the
managers we are ready the house calls
John Bolton the house calls John Bolton
the house calls Mick Mulvaney let's get
this trial started shall we
we are ready to present our case we are
ready to call our witnesses the question
is will you let us that is the question
before us now mr. Philbin says well if I
showed up in court and said I wasn't
ready the judge would throw me out of
the Court of course we're not saying
we're not ready but you know what
happened if mr. Philbin went into a
court and the judge said I've made a
deal with the defendant I'm not gonna
let the prosecutor call any witnesses
I'm not gonna let the prosecutor present
any documents you know who'd get thrown
out of the court the judge the judge be
taken out in handcuffs so let's step out
of this body for a moment imagine what a
real trial would look like it would
begin with the government receiving
documents being able to introduce
documents being able to call witnesses
this trial should be no different now
mr. Philbin makes reference to the
Cipollone e letter on october 18th which
followed a Cipollone e 8 page letter on
October 8th saying we're not going to do
anything you ask part law part diatribe
mostly diatribe you should read it
it's a letter basically that says what
the president said on that TV screen
which is we're gonna fight all subpoenas
the doctrine of absolute immunity that
counsel refers to has yes it has been
invoked or at least attempted by
presidents of both parties and rejected
uniformly by the courts including in the
most recent decision involving Don
McGann the president's former White
House Counsel where the court said that
would make him a king he's no king and
this trial is determined that he shall
not become a king accountable to no one
answerable to no one and what's more
this idea of absolute immunity this this
fever dream of presidents of both
parties it has no application to
documents again this amendment is on
documents there's no absolute immunity
from providing documents
and as representative Lofgren
Illustrated when this case has gone to
the Supreme Court in the Nixon case the
court held that the interest and
confidentiality in an appeasement
proceeding must give way to the
interests of the truth and the Senate
and the American people you cannot
invoke privilege to protect wrongdoing
you cannot invoke privilege to protect
evidence of a constitutional crime like
we have here and finally with respect to
those secret hearings that council keeps
referring to those secret depositions in
the house were so secret that only a
hundred members of Congress were able to
be there and participate only a hundred
that's how secret that chamber was
imagine that in the grand jury
proceedings in the Clinton investigation
or in the Jaworski the Nixon
investigation imagine inviting fifty or
hundred members of Congress to sit in on
those imagine as the president would
like hear apparently the president
assisting on having his lawyer in the
grand jury because it was a case being
investigated against him now we had no
grand jury here why is that why did we
have no grand juror here why was there
no special prosecutor here because the
Justice Department said they're not
going to look into this bill bars
Justice Department said there's nothing
to see here
if it were up to that Justice Department
you wouldn't know anything about this
that's why there was no grand jury
that's why we in the house had to do the
investigative work ourselves and yes
just like in the Nixon case just like in
the Clinton case we use depositions and
you know what deposition rules were used
that was terribly unfair deposition
rules we used they were written by the
Republicans we use the same rules that
the GOP House members used that's how
terribly unfair they were my gosh they
used our rules how dare they how dare
they and now why did we do up with
depositions because we didn't want one
witness to hear what another witness was
saying so they
could either tailor their stories or
know that they just had to admit so much
and no more it's how every credible
investigation works and this you know
the council could repeat all they like
that the president didn't have a chance
to participate didn't have a chance to
have council president and the Judiciary
Committee you know offer evidence they
could say it as much as they like it
doesn't make it any more true when they
make the same false representation time
and time again it just makes it that
much more deliberate and onerous
president could have presented evidence
in the Judiciary Committee he chose not
to and there's a reason for that there's
a reason why the witnesses they've
talked about aren't material witnesses
they don't go to the question of whether
the president withheld the aid for this
corrupt purpose they don't go to any of
that because they have no witnesses to
absolve the president on the facts you
should want to see these documents you
should want to see them you should want
to know what these private emails and
text messages have to say if you're
gonna make a decision about the
president's guilt or innocence you're
gonna make a decision about whether he
should be removed from office you should
want to see what these documents say now
if you don't care if you've made up your
mind that means the president my party
or for whatever reason I'm not
interested and what's more or I don't
really want the country to see this well
that's a wholly different matter but
that's that's not where your oath
requires it's not where your oath
requires the auth requires you to do
impartial justice which means to see the
evidence to see the evidence that's all
we're asking just don't blind yourself
to the evidence it's just I yield back
the majority leader is recognized I send
a motion to the desk to table the
amendment and ask for the yeas and nays
the question is on the motion to table
is there a sufficient second
there is the clerk will call the roll
mr. Alexander Ms Baldwin mr. Barroso mr.
Bennet mrs. Blackburn mr. Blumenthal mr.
blunt mr. Booker mr. Bozeman mr. Brahn
mr. Brown mr. burr Miss Cantwell mrs.
capito mr. Cardin mr. Carper mr. Casey
mr. Cassidy Ms Collins mr. Coons mr.
Cornyn miss Cortez Masto mr. cotton mr.
Kramer
mr. Creepo mr. Cruz mr. Danes Ms
Duckworth mr. Durbin mr. n z ms Ernst
mrs. Feinstein miss
Fisher mr. Gardner mrs. Gillibrand mr.
Graham mr. Grassley MS Harris miss
Hassan mr. Hawley mr. Heinrich miss her
oh no mr. Hoeven mrs. Hyde Smith mr.
Inhofe mr. Johnson mr. Jones mr. Caine
mr. Kennedy mr. king miss Klobuchar
mr. Lankford mr. Lahey
mr. Lee mrs. Leffler mr. mansion mr.
markey mr. MacConnell MS mcsalley mr.
Menendez mr. Merkley mr. Moran Ms
Murkowski mr. Murphy mrs. Marie mr. Paul
mr. Perdue mr. peters mr. Portman mr.
Reid
mr. rish mr. Roberts
mr. Romney MS Rosen mr. rounds mr. Rubio
mr. Sanders mr. sass mr. schat's
mr. Schumer mr. Scott of Florida mr.
Scott of South Carolina mrs. Shaheen mr.
Shelby MS cinema Miss Smith miss
Stabenow mr. Sullivan mr. tester mr.
foon mr. Tillis mr. Jimmy mr. Udall mr.
Van Hollen mr. Warner MS Warren mr.
Whitehouse mr. wicker mr. Wyden mr.
young
are there any Senators in the chamber
wishing to vote or change his or her
vote if not the yeas are 53 the nays are
47 the amendment is tabled mr.
Democratic leader is recognized mr.
Chief Justice I send an amendment to the
desk to subpoena certain documents and
records from the State Department and I
ask that it be read the clerk will read
the amendment the senator from New York
mr. Schumer proposes an amendment number
12 85 at the appropriate place in the
resolving Clause insert the following
section notwithstanding any other
provision of this resolution pursuant to
rules 5 & 6 of the rules or procedures
and practice in the Senate when sitting
in impeachment trials 1 the Chief
Justice of the United States through the
Secretary of the Senate shall issue a
subpoena to the Secretary of Senate
commanding him to produce for the time
period from January 1 2019 to the
present all documents communications and
other records within the possession
custody or control of the Department of
State
referring or relating to a all meetings
and calls between President Trump and
the president of Ukraine including
documents communications and other
records related to the scheduling of
preparation for and follow-up from the
president's April 21 and July 25 2019
telephone calls as well as the
president's 20 September 25 2009 teen
meeting with the president of Ukraine in
New York be the actual potential
suspension withholding delaying freezing
or releasing of United States foreign
assistance military assistance or
security assistance of any kind to
Ukraine
including but not limited to the Ukraine
security assistance initiative USA I and
foreign military financing FMF including
but not limited to all communications
with the White House Department of
Defense and the Office of Management and
Budget as well as the Ukrainian
government's knowledge prior to August
28 2019 of any actual or potential
suspension withholding delaying freezing
or releasing of United States foreign
assistance to Ukraine including all
meetings calls or other engagements with
Ukrainian officials regarding potential
or actual suspensions holds or delays in
United States assistance to Ukraine see
all documents communications notes and
other records created or received by
Secretary Michael are Pompeo counselor T
Ulrich Brett ball former Special
Representative for Ukraine negotiations
ambassador Kurt Volker deputy assistant
secretary George Kent then United States
Embassy in Ukraine charge d'affaires
william b taylor an ambassador to the
european union gordon Sandlin and other
state Department officials relating to
efforts to 1 solicit requests demand
induced persuade or coerce Ukraine to
conduct or announce investigations to
schedule cancel or withhold a White
House meeting for Ukraine's president or
three hold and then release military and
other Secretary's security assistance to
Ukraine D any meetings or proposed
meetings at at or involving the White
House that relate to Ukraine including
but not limited to one president
zelinsky's inauguration on May 20 2009
teen in Kiev Ukraine including but not
limited to president Trump's decision
not to attend to ask vice president
pence to lead the delegation directing
vice president pence not to attend and
the subsequent decision about the
composition of the delegation of the
United States to a meeting at the White
House on or around May 23 2009 teen
involving among others president Trump
then Special Representative for Ukraine
negotiations ambassador Kurt Volker then
energy secretary
Rick Perry and United States ambassador
to the European Union
Gordon Sandlin as well as any private
meetings or conversations with those
individuals before or after the larger
meeting three meetings at the White
House on or about July 10 2019 involving
Ukrainian officials Andrei uremic and
Alexander Daniel ik and United States
government officials including but not
limited to the National Security Advisor
John Bolton Secretariat Perry ambassador
Volcker and ambassador Sandlin to
include at least a meeting and
ambassador Bolton's office and a
subsequent meeting in the wardroom for a
meeting at the White House on or around
August 30 2019 involving President Trump
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo and
Secretary of Defense mark Esper five a
planned meeting later canceled in Warsaw
Poland on or around September 1 2019
between president trapped and president
szalinski and subsequently attended by
Vice President pence and six a meeting
at the White House on or around
September 11 2009 teen involving
President Trump vice president pence and
mr. Mulvaney concerning the lifting of
the hold on security assistance for
Ukraine II all communications including
but not limited to whatsapp or text
messages on private devices between
current or former State Department
officials or employees including but not
limited to secretary Michael are Pompeo
ambassador Volcker ambassador Sandlin
ambassador Taylor and Deputy Assistant
Secretary Kent and the following
president szalinski Andrei uremic or
individuals or entities associated with
or acting in any capacity as a
representative agent or proxy for
president szalinski before and after his
election all records specifically
identified by witnesses in the House of
Representatives impeachment inquiry that
memorialized key events or concerns and
any records reflecting an official
response there - including but not
limited to one on August 29 2009 teen
cable sent by ambassador Taylor to
secretary Pompeo - in August 16 2019
memorandum - file written
by Deputy Assistant Secretary Kent and
three a September 15 2009 teen
memorandum to file written by Deputy
Assistant Secretary Ken G all meetings
are calls including but not limited to
all requests for or records of meetings
or telephone calls scheduling items
calendar entries State Department
visitor records and email or text
messages using personal or work related
devices between or among one current or
former State Department officials or
employees including but not limited to
secretary Michael our Pompeo ambassador
Volcker and ambassador Sandlin and to
Rudolf W Giuliani Victoria tensing or
Joseph digenova an H the curtailment or
recall a former United States Ambassador
to Ukraine Marie Masha
Jovanovic for the United States Embassy
in Kiev including credible threat
reports against her and any protective
security measures taken in response and
to the sergeant-at-arms is authorized to
utilize the services of the deputy
sergeant arms or any other employee of
the Senate and serving the subpoena
authorized to be issued by this section
mr. Chief Justice the majority leader is
recognized and now for a brief 10-minute
recess before the parties are recognized
to debate the Schumer amendment at the
end of the debate time I'll again move
to table the amendment as the timing of
these votes are specified in the
underlying resolution so I ask consent
that the Senate stand in recess subject
to the call of the chair without
objection the Senate is in recess
her name was there